CONTINUED REPORTING FROM THE
BORDER THERE.
THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS POLL DRIVEN.
THEY SAY TRUST THE SIGNS.
IT HAS BEEN TRUST THE POLLS,
TRUST THE TEACHERS UNION.
IT WAS A FEW WEEKS INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION WE GOT EMAILS
THE CDC DOCTOR WAS TALKING WITH
THE AFT GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOLS.
TAKING WHAT THE TEACHERS UNION
SAID VERSUS THE DOCTORS AT CDC.
THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN OVER THE
PLACE AND DRIVEN BY POLITICS.
>> Bill: RUB CANS QUESTIONING
THE TIMING OF THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
SAYING LONG OVERDUE IN LIGHT OF
THE SCIENCE.
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE THE SENIOR
ADVISOR FOR THE COVID-19
RESPONSE ANDY SLAVITT.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME BACK.
>> Bill: DID YOU WEAR A MASK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE THIS MORNING?
>> I DID NOT.
>> Bill: WHAT CHANGED?
>> THE CDC OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS GATHERED EVIDENCE
WHICH SHOWED THEM THREE THINGS.
ONE, WE HAVE A DROP NOW IN
CASES.
WORKS THE SAME WAY WHEN IT GOES
DOWN WHEN IT GOES UP.
30% DROP IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO.
SECONDLY, THERE IS EVIDENCE
THAT THE VACCINES WORK AT
PREVENTING THE SPREAD WHICH
MANY SUSPECTED BUT THEY HAVE
GOOD DATA ON, INCLUDING THEY
HAVE DATA THAT THE VACCINES ARE
EFFECTIVE AGAINST THE VARIANTS,
A PIECE OF INFORMATION THEY
WERE WAITING FOR.
FINALLY, EVERY AMERICAN NOW
OVER 12 IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
VACCINE.
IT IS HARD TO -- WE HAVE PLENTY
OF VACCINE SUPPLY.
THOSE THREE FACTORS TOGETHER
WHAT THE CDC EXPLAINED TO US IS
WHY THEY DECIDED IT WAS TIME TO
SAY IF YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED
YOU DON'T NEED TO WEAR YOUR
MASK.
>> Bill: A CHANCE TO CHALLENGE
YOU ON THAT.
36 HOURS AGO THE HEAD OF THE
CDC SAID NO CHANGE AND DR.
FAUCI SAID THE SAME THING AS
WELL.
SEVEN DAYS AGO THEY WERE
TELLING 12-YEAR-OLDS TO WEAR A
MASK AT SUMMER CAMP IN JULY.
IT IS A SWAP.
ADMIRAL BRETT GIROIR WAS IN
YOUR SPOT FOR THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION PART OF
OPERATION WARP SPEED SAID THIS
ABOUT 90 MINUTES AGO.
>> WHO KNOWS WHAT TOOK THE CDC
SO LONG?
IT PROBABLY COULD HAVE BEEN
DONE A MONTH AGO.
DR. WALENSKY WAS INTRANSIENT IN
HER POSITION.
YESTERDAY MORNING DR. FAUCI
SAID YOU STILL NEED TO WEAR A
MASK INDOORS AND OUTDOORS IN A
CROWD.
BY THE AFTERNOON IT WAS ALL
OVER.
THEY PROBABLY GOT SOME
POLITICAL DIRECTION AND MADE
THE CHANGE.
I WELCOME THE CHANGE.
WE SHOULD ALL WELCOME THE
CHANGE AND SUPPORTED BY THE
SCIENCE AND A GOOD THING FOR
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Bill: JUST RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE ALLEGATIONS HE IS LAYING
DOWN IN THE COMMENT.
>> CDC GUIDANCE WILL BE WHAT IT
IS UNTIL IT CHANGES.
WE DIDN'T FIND OUT AT THE WHITE
HOUSE UNTIL 9:00 P.M. THE NIGHT
BEFORE THAT THE CDC WAS GOING
TO MAKE THIS CHANGE YESTERDAY.
IF THEY WANTED TO DO THIS
POLITICALLY CONVENIENTLY
WOULDN'T YOU HAVE DONE THIS
BEFORE THE HEARING SO SHE
DIDN'T HAVE TO TAKE THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS RATHER THAN AFTER?
THE CDC WILL BE CRITICIZED AT
THE SAME TIME.
TODAY THEY GOT IT FROM BOTH
SIDE BEFORE THEY MADE THE
CHANGE.
THE JOB ISN'T TO BE POPULAR.
THEY TRY TO FOLLOW THE SIGNS.
OUR JOB AT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
LET THEM FOLLOW THE SCIENCE AND
TAKE WHAT COMES AND TRY TO
EXPLAIN IT AS BEST WE CAN TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
I KNOW IT IS A SHOCK TO PEOPLE.
SOME SAY IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE LONG AGO.
OTHERS ARE SAYING THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO ADJUST TO IT.
BOTTOM LINE THEY FOUND EVIDENCE
THAT TELLS THEM THAT YOU DON'T
NEED TO WEAR A MASK IF YOU'RE
VACCINATED AND IF YOU ARE, YOU
ARE STILL IN DANGER AND SHOULD
WEAR A MASK.
>> Bill: HAVE YOU SPOKEN WITH
DR. WALENSKY FROM THE CDC?
>> WE DID A PRESS CONFERENCE
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON.
I THINK IT WAS YESTERDAY AFTER
THE DECISION TO TALK TO THE
PUBLIC.
>> Bill: YOU DID A PRESS
CONFERENCE ON THURSDAY, THAT
HAPPENED?
>> YES.
>> Bill: THE STATES REVIEWING
THE GUIDANCE BUT NOT YET
FOLLOWING IT OR IMPLEMENTING IT
IS THE WORD WE'LL USE HERE.
A LOT OF THESE ARE BLUE STATES.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE
GOVERNORS?
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE MAYORS
THAT ARE MAKING POLICY IN THOSE
STATES?
>> TWO THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS WHAT THE
SCIENCE SAYS.
SO IF THE SCIENCE TELLS US THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
PLUS TWO WEEKS ARE SAFE, YOU
HAVE TO TELL THE PUBLIC WHAT
THE SCIENCE SAYS.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS GUIDANCE.
WHAT DOES EVERY STATE AND
EMPLOYER DO?
WHAT DO WE AS INDIVIDUALS DO?
THOSE DECISIONS ARE UP TO US
AND BUSINESSES AND STATES.
THE CDC WILL GO THROUGH ALL ITS
GUIDANCE NOW, SUMMER CAMPS,
BUSINESSES, TRAVEL, ETC.  AND
OVER THE NEXT PERIOD OF TIME
THEY HAVE THOUSANDS OF PIECES
OF GUIDANCE OUT.
THEY'LL UPDATE ALL THE GUIDANCE.
THEY WANTED TO PUT THE
CONCLUSION OUT THERE
RECOGNIZING THEY WILL HAVE TO
UPDATE THE REST OF THE GUIDANCE
BUT FELT IT WAS FAIR TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC TO SAY IF
YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED YOU
DON'T NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
>> Bill: A REMARKABLE TURN
AROUND IN 47 DAYS WHEN YOU GO
FROM IMPENDING DOOM AND THE
COMMENT SAYING YOU'RE SCARED TO
THIS.
LET'S HOPE IT